Brazilian federal police at the home of
former President Jed bolsonaro on
Thursday police confiscated bolsonaro's
passport and search warrants were
carried out against several members of
his inner circle Bolado and his former
AIDS are accused of plotting a military
coup to remain in power after his
presidential defeat in October of
2022 his supporters would later storm
the Congress and buildings housing the
presidential Palace and Supreme Court
bson denied any wrongdoing and called
the investigation against him a
political
persecution Brazil's current president
luio Lula da Silva has called for
patience as the investigations move
forward but has also offered his own
criticism of the former
president he was in government he wasn't
prepared to win he wasn't prepared to
lose he wasn't prepared to leave so much
so that he didn't even have the courage
to say congratulations he went home
crying and traveled to the United States
cuz he must have participated in the
construction of this C attempt so let's
wait for the investigations shortly
before the storming of the Congress and
the inauguration of Lula da Silva bonaro
traveled to the United States returning
3 months later from a self-imposed Exile
police said those being targeted are
accused of participating in a criminal
organization that was aimed at keeping
the former Brazilian president in power
this is the type of thing you see before
an arrest warrant is issued what's
interesting here is that when a passport
is requested from you it implies there's
concern over a Flight Risk which means
there could be an upcoming
trial last week federal police raided
properties belonging to bonar's son
Carlos as part of a separate probe
linked to the alleged spying of
political opponents during bolsonaro's
time in office Manuel r
Al make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer